hello and welcome i'm james murphy and
in this episode we're going to be
talking about a curious idiom not not x
and how using not not x actually turns
out to be faster than using the built-in
bool operator on x
so i actually had a viewer comment and
ask james could you cover why this not
not x thing is faster than boolex and
when i first read this comment i thought
to myself
there's no way right i mean
they're computing the same thing
not not x is just going to call the you
know boolean conversion operator for x
just like bool does how could one be any
faster or slower than the other
but i thought about it for a little
while and then i decided i would at
least test it
and so i wrote up a little script to
test it and here's what i found
quite surprisingly bull took 1.08
seconds for 10 million trials versus
only 0.68 seconds for not not x you can
see the testing code that i used here
just have 10 million trials and then i
use the built-in time it dot time it in
order to time each of the functions
so since i'm using 10 million trials
that's why these are in seconds and not
in tenths of a microsecond
no matter how many times i run it i've
tried changing the order of the tests
all of the different ways that i've
tried it bool x always takes much longer
than not not x so how can that be and
why
the first thing to note is that bool
like any other name is a variable and
you have to look up that variable in
this case in the global scope so this
function involves looking up the name
bool whereas this function doesn't have
to look anything up it's always going to
call the boolean conversion operator
because there's no way to override not
like there is a way to override bool for
instance i could just say bool equals
stir and you know that changes the value
that bool is here now bool is pointing
to the built-in stir instead of to the
built-in bool
so
because this value of bool can change it
has to be looked up at runtime so i went
ahead and added this y equals bool line
into this conversion function it doesn't
actually do anything as far as the
return value is concerned it's just
trying to put it on a level playing
field so in this case
this function now also has to look up
the name bool but as we see from the
runtimes
not not x is still faster so it's not
the lookup of the name bool which is
causing the slowdown it's something else
for this test i'm doing something very
similar which is i'm still looking up
the name bool but in this case i'm also
actually calling the bull function i'm
just default constructing a boolean so
that's going to give me true and i'm
storing it and then not doing anything
with it and still just returning not not
x
but in this case we can see that the
times are very very closely aligned just
0.93 and 0.94
what this is telling me is essentially
that the slowdown is caused by how slow
it is to actually call a function in
python
not not x doesn't actually go through
the mechanism of calling a function in
python it actually has a special fast
path programmed in which allows it to
execute just directly going to the
boolean conversion rather than calling
the bool function which then does the
conversion
that's why adding the unnecessary name
lookup and function call basically makes
the times equal again
we can confirm our intuition by plugging
the functions into compiler explorer and
looking at the output
so
this top four set of instructions is the
code for the bool convert function once
it's been compiled into bytecode as you
can see there's the load global or the
bool operator so it has to load bool and
then it loads the local variable x and
then calls the function which is the
bool that was just loaded and then
returns
whereas in the not not conversion
there's a special instruction called
unary not which gets called twice
instead of calling any function
just for completeness here's what you
see when you throw back in the redundant
read
so in this case this instruction you can
see when i hover my mouse over it it
highlights the three instructions on the
right here
that instruction corresponds to loading
the global pool then calling that
function and storing it in the variable
y
in particular you can see that even
though the variable y isn't used later
in the function and it could
theoretically just be removed and
optimized away those kinds of
optimizations generally don't happen
when you compile things into python byte
code there are some situations where
things get compiled ahead of time like
if you add two constant integers
together but most of the time
you will actually see redundant
operations even if there's basically no
chance that they could ever be used in
the actual code
so that's pretty cool that we can
explain what exactly is the difference
between knot knot and bullex and this is
how we're making up the difference in
time but for now let's just get rid of
this redundant read and compare to a few
other things
so down here i also have
how long does it take to call the
double under or dunderbool function of
the variable and also i'm comparing to
just a no op
looking at the times of course we find
that the no op just a function call that
passes does nothing
is the fastest followed by the not not
and then the
method call of the dunderbool and then
the calling of the global bull take
about the same amount of time now i did
run this a few times and it seemed like
most of the time actually the method
call was even slower but just by a
little bit
i think that most of the time though you
don't really care about converting an x
to a bool what you really want is to
just use it in an if statement so let's
also compare against uh doing just an if
x versus an if not not x
thankfully we see that in this case both
if x and if not not x are on par with
just a little bit slower than a no op
function call so if x and if not not x
are not calling the bool function as a
function and then doing stuff it
definitely has a fast path
which is converting the x to a pool in a
different way and i actually have a
whole video on that if you want to check
it out additionally the times for if x
and if not not x are very close so i
wonder if they're doing anything
different
interestingly when we plug the example
into compiler explorer we see that an
optimization is actually happening here
if x is being converted into these four
instructions we see load and then pop
jump if false and then a load and return
if not not x you can compare line for
line is doing the exact same thing
that means that there is literally no
difference in the byte code between if x
and if not nonex so please don't write
not not x that's just going to confuse
people just write if x
so speaking of not confusing people
suppose you're in a situation where you
do actually want to call bool x you're
not just going to use x in an if
statement immediately later you actually
want to store the value of the boolean
conversion
in that case is it worth it to use not
not x and potentially confuse your
readers instead of just calling bool x
i'm going to go ahead and say no you
should always just be using bool x
although the difference in timing
between not not x and bool x is going to
be significant in the statistical sense
it's definitely not going to be
significant in the real world sense
remember this was for 10 million
iterations
so we still have a pretty small
difference in 10 million iterations so
unless you're counting tenths of a
microsecond then you really shouldn't be
caring about whether you use not not x
or boulex so just use the one that's
more readable
and if you are counting tenths of a
millisecond then you probably shouldn't
be doing whatever you're doing in python
well just because the video told you to
keep doing what you were probably
already doing doesn't mean it wasn't
interesting right in any case thank you
as always to my patrons and donors if
you especially like my video please
consider becoming a subscriber or
becoming a patron or donor i really
appreciate the support don't forget to
slap that like button an odd number of
times of course and i'll see you next
time thanks for watching